what do you remember from being on that
set because the brat pack was a really
really big deal I mean you it was a it
was such a cultural phenomenon and we
kind of like did because it was us we
were like whatever you know what I mean
but people loved it and then it was the
fact that we're still that we still talk
about it's so cool like it's like being
in the original Rat Pack yes right away
right that's what it matriculated there
hadn't been somebody since the Rat Pack
that was that popular so they just threw
a B on it and called it a day who was
the naughtiest there
uh I'm sad to say it was me
okay then like just flip it to Wayne's
World
[Music]
that was um I was uh I did that movie
right I had to come back from my
honeymoon
to do that movie should my wife and I
just gotten married we got to Cabo San
Lucas my wife Cheryl this will be our
32nd wedding anniversary
[Applause]
to me out of my honeymoon did you ever
get a redo I did good I finally did a
redo okay good okay good oh my God you
guys are so amazing okay Tommy Boy I
mean
that's seen as the cow tipping scene yes
um I'm from Ohio cow tipping is a real
thing
we really do it the writers of that show
could not believe they thought I was
making it up they thought it was a bit I
told them about it and they put that
scene in the script and that was my
contribution to the script of Tommy Boy
I mean
and Chris Farley amazing oh my God I
loved him so much I would take him to
dinner he would order two steaks two
porterhouse steaks and on top of each
bite he would put a cube of butter
and when I would look at him and be like
Chris what are you doing it needs hat
a butter hat a butter hat a butter hat
oh my gosh Julia Child says yes yes
um okay Austin Powers the spy who
shagged me
foreign
golf with Mike Myers who'd become my
friends since Wayne's World Wayne's
World and he had done the first Austin
Powers with Robert Wagner who I knew
growing up through Katie Wagner and and
that group
Natasha so I grew up with Dr with RJ
Robert Wagner I grew up with him and I
said how was it working with RJ to Mike
Myers he was oh my God that's an amazing
Robert Wagner impersonation and six
months later he showed me the script of
Austin Powers 2 and he had written that
into the movie with me playing young
rubber wagons it's so brilliant
okay The West Wing
yes
the biggest show Aaron Sorkin another
cultural phenomena what was it like
doing that I knew when I read the uh
that very first script it was one of the
best things I'd ever read and um I don't
know if you've ever had this when you
read a screenplay and go oh
not only am I going to play this part
but I'm the only person who can play
that part it doesn't happen all the time
but sometimes it happens doesn't it and
that's what I felt like when I read Sam
Seaborn well what about parks and rats
because
[Applause]
that's another like it was a hit in the
time and it's a cult classic I I love
that photo so much oh Amy Poehler I love
her so much was that I mean that was the
best cast like the best group of people
was it just so much fun and and the
friendships that endure from it you know
we're all still really really good
friends I see Chris Pratt all the time
um Catherine Schwarzenegger his wife is
uh my wife is Catherine's godmother oh
my God
isn't that weird so like it all comes
around like she was like Chris Pratt
asked me out on a date I'm like
Chris Chris my Chris
so and what did you say I was like do it
immediately he's the best so amazing and
Aubry Plaza said you guys are like on a
group tag there's a group text that
still exists do you know how much life
that gives everybody thank you
wait and just stick around because
you're gonna meet Rob Lowe's son which
you've probably already met on social
media because actually of the cute
antagonistic relationship you have this
show sort of sparked a fire and the
people who made your show are the same
people I made Santa Clarita diet with
that's right so we have I mean
all right
[Music]